من مدرس للجغرافيا الى بطل في حرب كبرى
وليست الحرب العالميه الثانيه ايه حرب
فكيف اذا كان المحارب الاخير الذي راوغا
خصومه الامريكين مرارا وتكرارا انه ساكن
اوبا ثعلب جزيره سيبان الذي احنى رؤوس
خصومه قبل ان يلقي سيفا فما قصته
بدا اوبا حياته المهنيه مدرسا للجغرافيا
والضم الى الجيش الياباني عام
1934 وهو في العشرين من عمره
العالميه الثانيه حيث تم ارساله في عام
1944 على راس فريق المساعدات الطبيه الى
جزيره سايبه
لكن الوحده تتعرضت للهجوم في معركه خليجته
اعظم معركه بحريه في التاريخ ما تسبب في
غرق اكثر من 2300 جندي فيما نجا اوبا
بعجوبه
جمع اوبا النجيل من زملائه واعاده تنظيم
وحدته لكن القوه الامريكيه غازات الجزيره
وقتلت الكثير منهم ولم يبقى سوى 30,000
جنديا ياباني انتشروا في المناطق الداخليه
الوعره للجزيره
بحلول السابع من يوليو اجتاح اكثر من 4000
جندي يابانيه الجزيره للدفاع عنها
لكنهم هزموا وقضي عليهم في اقل من 15 ساعه
لكن اوبا نجا مره اخرى فقام بجمع اكثر من
350 جنديا ومدنيا
وسحبهم لمخابئ بالجزيره
وقام معهم بغارات متفرقه على القوه
الامريكيه فدمروا بعض معداتهم كما تسلل
مرارا لمعسكراتهم لجمع الطعام والاخبار
قامت القوه الامريكيه بحمله لايجاد
المجموعه المختلئه واعتقلت عددا قليلا من
كبار السن لكنها لم تمسك باوبا ما دفعها
لتلقيبه بثعلب سيبان لجرته وحظه
في بدايه عام
1945 وبعد ثلاثه اشهر من انتهاء الحرب خرج
اوبا من الغابه على راس قواته المتبقيه
لمقابله المقدمه هوارد كورجيتس في مشات
البحريه الامريكيه وسلم سيفه بينما
استسلمت قواته وبعد 17 شهرا قضاها اوبا
ورفاقه بالجزيره التقط مصور في البحريه
الامريكيه لقطه للحظه وعلق عليها انه
انتهى القتال في سايبان اخيرا
تقديرا لما اثره تم تكريمه اوبا من قبل
نادي ضباط البحريه الامريكيه في الجزيره
قبل اعادته الى اليابان
وانحنو لمصافحته فيما اقيم احتفال له
وللجنود العائدين باليابان كما تم تجريده
من ترقيته الى رتبه رائد التي تم منحها له
اعتقادا بانه توفي اثناء المهم تم توثيق
مسيره اوبا من قبل النقيب العريف دونجا
احد قدام المحاربين الامريكيين في حمله
سايبا كما اسهم في اعاده السيف لاوبا لانه
علم ان السيف بالنسبه للساموراي اكثر
بكثير من مجرد سلاح عادي
توفي اوبا عام
1992 ولكن ذكراه بقيت حيه في سجل الابطال
كمقاوم وطنيه استحق احترام خصومه قبل
ابناء جده